(dramatic music)
- Whenever you say Spider-Man,
you always mean the other one.
You're Spider-Man.
♪ I'm fresher than fresh ♪
♪ I step up the steps, I'm
wall runnin' for the flex ♪
♪ Pete told me I was next ♪
♪ I'm comin' for next, there
really isn't no question ♪
♪ Only superheros
in this section ♪
♪ Only big bangers
on the set list ♪
♪ On top of buildings
where I eat breakfast ♪
♪ Then I shine like
a new necklace ♪
♪ I'm ready to go,
she callin' my phone ♪
♪ Girl I'm comin' over ♪
♪ I got something to prove,
showing the whole world ♪
♪ Can't hold it no longer ♪
♪ They think I'm way
too young to stand up ♪
♪ For the ones I love, but
let me tell you something ♪
♪ Ooh ♪
♪ I'm ready, I'm ready,
I'm ready, I'm ready ♪
♪ To take on the
world, I'm ready ♪
♪ You can't stop me now ♪
♪ Ahhh ♪
♪ Ooh ♪
♪ I'm ready, I'm ready,
I'm ready, I'm ready ♪
♪ To take on the
world, I'm ready ♪
♪ You can't stop me now ♪
♪ Ahhh ♪
♪ Yeah, girl I'm the
one gotta tell 'em ♪
♪ Young with a vision,
man they couldn't see it ♪
♪ Man just let the
picture develop ♪
♪ I got a... Yeah ♪
♪ Fly as a whip
with propellers ♪
♪ All of these
villains are jealous ♪
♪ Just 'cause I'm young
and I'm careless ♪
♪ Swinging thru the
window what an entrance ♪
♪ I'm ready to go,
she callin' my phone ♪
♪ Girl I'm comin' over ♪
♪ I got something to prove,
showing the whole world ♪
♪ Can't hold no longer ♪
♪ They think I'm way
too young to stand up ♪
♪ For the ones I love, but
let me tell you something ♪
♪ Ooh ♪
♪ I'm ready, I'm ready,
I'm ready, I'm ready ♪
♪ To take on the
world, I'm ready ♪
♪ You can't stop me now ♪
♪ Ahhh ♪
♪ You know who you are ♪
♪ Big drip on the roof top ♪
♪ Gotta fight for the
truth in this war ♪
♪ Don't let the city go dark ♪
♪ You know who you are ♪
♪ The swag they fill up
the shoes they kill them ♪
♪ Meanwhile I'm
fightin' the villain ♪
♪ She know what the deal is,
the clique full of heroes ♪
♪ She made me moonwalk
on the ceiling ♪
♪ Just ask, they
know we the illest ♪
♪ Spidey senses full of vision ♪
♪ Then when they think
they can get us ♪
♪ They checkin' the drip when
I flip off the building yeah ♪
♪ Ooh ♪
♪ I'm ready, I'm ready,
I'm ready, I'm ready ♪
♪ To take on the
world, I'm ready ♪
♪ You can't stop me now ♪
♪ Ahhh ♪
♪ Ooh ♪
♪ I'm ready, I'm ready,
I'm ready, I'm ready ♪
♪ To take on the
world, I'm ready ♪
♪ You can't stop me now ♪
♪ Ahhh ♪
(dramatic music)
- Men, you still can't
get over that suit.
So cool!
- Gotta be me.
- Yeah, you do!
- [Narrator] Play Station.